EXCLUSIVE CNN
REPORTING IN TO US.
A SOURCE REVEALING, GET THIS,
ANOTHER DISCOVERY OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
ROUGHLY A DOZEN GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS WERE UNCOVERED AT THE
HOME OF FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE.
THAT HOME IS IN INDIANA.
THE SEARCH TOOK PLACE LAST WEEK.
THE DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND BY ONE
OF THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYERS.
THE FBI WAS IMMEDIATELY
NOTIFIED.
THIS FIND, OF COURSE, FLIES IN
THE FACE OF REPEATED PENCE
DENIALS HE HELD ON TO ANY
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS WHEN HE
LEFT THE GOVERNMENT, THE
BACKDROP TO TWO SEPARATE SPECIAL
COUNSELS ALREADY INVESTIGATING
THE CURRENT AND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN AND DONALD
TRUMP, FOR POTENTIAL BREACHES AS
WELL AND HOW THEY HANDLED
GOVERNMENT SECRETS.
OUR CNN SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT
JAMIE GANGEL IS BREAKING THIS,
EVAN PEREZ WITH US, JAMIE, WALK
US THROUGH WHAT WE KNOW.
>> SO MORE DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS NOW NUMBER THREE, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE OUT OF
AN ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION, WE ARE
TOLD HE HAD A LAWYER GO THROUGH
HIS HOUSE AND DOUBLE-CHECK
BOXES.
THEY FOUND FOUR BOXES IN HIS
HOME IN INDIANA.
THEY SAY THEY HAD BEEN SEALED
SINCE THE TIME HE LEFT HIS VICE
PRESIDENT.
THEY GO THROUGH THE BOXES AND
FOUND ROUGHLY 12 DOCUMENTS THAT
HAVE -- APPEAR TO HAVE CLA
CLASSIFIED MARKINGS ON THEM.
THEY IMMEDIATELY CALLED -- THIS
WAS LAST WEEK.
THEY IMMEDIATELY CALLED THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES TO HAND THEM
OVER.
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THE
ARCHIVES BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON WITH BIDEN AND
TRUMP ALERTED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE NIGHT OF
JANUARY 19th, THE FBI CAME TO
THE PENCE HOME IN INDIANA AND
THEY HANDED OVER THOSE 12
DOCUMENTS.
FOR CLARITY, THESE BOXES HAVE
NOT BEEN STORED IN A SECURE
PLACE.
THEY'VE BEEN IN HIS HOME, BUT
I'M TOLD THEY WERE SEALED.
HOWEVER, WHEN THE LAWYER FOUND
THESE 12 DOCUMENTS, THEY TOOK
THE 12 DOCUMENTS AND KEPT THEM
IN A SAFE UNTIL THE FBI CAME.
>> AND SO THIS IS NOT TO PICK ON
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE I THINK WE NOW HAVE SEEN
THIS CAN HAPPEN BUT IN NOVEMBER.
>> RIGHT.
>> AS THE TRUMP STORY WAS
BREAKING WE DID NOT KNOW AT THIS
POINT ABOUT THE BIDEN STORY.
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT SAT
DOWN WITH ABC NEWS AND IT WAS
QUITE DIRECT.
>> DID YOU TAKE ANY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS WITH YOU FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE?
>> I DID NOT.
>> DO YOU SEE ANY REASON FOR
ANYONE TO TAKE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS WITH THEM LEAVING THE
WHITE HOUSE?
>> WELL, THERE WOULD BE NO
REASON TO HAVE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS PARTICULARLY IF THEY
WERE IN AN UNPROTECTED AREA.
>> WELL, THERE WERE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND THEY WERE IN, AS
YOU REPORT, AN UNPROTECTED AREA.
>> RIGHT.
>> DO THEY HAVE ANY EXPLANATION.
I DON'T SAY THAT TO PICK ON THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT WHO IS A
CAUTIOUS, METICULOUS PERSON BUT
YET AGAIN THIS HAS HAPPENED.
>> LOOK, WE WENT THROUGH THIS
WITH BIDEN.
HE SAID HE WAS SURPRISED.
I THINK IT'S CLEAR FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE WAS SURPRISED AS
WELL.
THESE DO SEEM TO BE INADVERTENT.
THAT SAID HOW DID IT HAPPEN?
OUR REPORTING IS THAT IN THE
FINAL DAYS OF PACKING UP BOTH
THE WEST WING, THE WHITE HOUSE
OFFICE AND THE RESIDENCE OFFICE
THAT THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
WERE LIKELY AT THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S RESIDENCE AND THEY
DID NOT GO THROUGH THE SAME
RIGOROUS CHECKING THAT WAS
HAPPENING OVER AT THE WHITE
HOUSE AND SO THEY GOT PACKED UP
WITH PERSONAL THINGS THAT WERE
COMING FROM THE RESIDENCE.
>> AGAIN, TO THAT POINT WHAT YOU
JUST SAID, LISTEN, THIS IS THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS IS TALKING TO FOX BUSINESS
THIS MONTH IN JANUARY, ON
JANUARY 12th SAYING I WAS EXTRA
CAREFUL.
LISTEN.
>> I RECEIVED A PRESIDENTIAL
DAILY BRIEF AT THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S RESIDENCE.
I'D RISE EARLY.
I'D GO TO THE SAFE WHERE MY
MILITARY AIDE WOULD PLACE THOSE
CLASSIFIED MATERIALS, I'D PULL
THEM OUT, REVIEW THEM.
I'D RECEIVE A PRESENTATION TO
THEM AND THEN FRANKLY MORE OFTEN
THAN NOT, LARRY, I WOULD SIMPLY
RETURN THEM BACK TO THE FILE
THAT I'D RECEIVED THEM IN.
THEY WENT IN COMMONLY INTO WHAT
WAS CALLED A BURN BAG THAT MY
MILITARY AIDE WOULD GATHER AND
THEN DESTROY THOSE CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS.
SAME GOES IN MATERIALS THAT I
WOULD RECEIVE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> SO, AGAIN, IN BOTH INTERVIEWS
HE'S SPEAKING WITH CERTAINTY.
NOT ME, DIDN'T HAPPEN.
NOT AN UNPROTECTED PLACE.
WE HAD A PROCESS AND YET --
>> SO THERE'S NO QUESTION
THINGS -- THE SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING AND BIG PICTURE, WHAT
I'M TOLD BY SOURCES WHO DEAL
WITH THE ARCHIVES AND
PRESIDENTIAL MATERIAL HAVE SAID
IS THIS IS YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE,
THE SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING, THEY
NEED TO GO BACK, REVIEW RECORDS
MANAGEMENT, REVIEW CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL MANAGEMENT, WE'RE ALSO
TOLD, SO WHY DID AFTER SAYING NO
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
REPEATEDLY, THEY CLEARLY WENT
BACK AND FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE WANTED TO TRIPLE CHECK
BECAUSE OF THE BIDEN DOCUMENTS.
>> TO HIS CREDIT MOST LIKELY.
THE MOST LIKELY TO HIS CREDIT
AGAIN, SO, EVAN, THERE WAS A
TRUMP INVESTIGATION ALREADY
UNDER WAY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
BIDEN DISCLOSURE HAPPENED PRETTY
MUCH HAD NO CHOICE.
HE WOULDN'T SAY IT THIS WAY BUT
THEN DID A SPECIAL COUNSEL FOR
THE BIDEN INVESTIGATION SO THE
CURRENT AND FORMER PRESIDENT
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
IN A MOMENT WE'LL GET INTO THEIR
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES IN THE
INVESTIGATION -- IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING NOW I
THINK PENCE AS WELL.
WHAT NOW AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
>> WELL NOW THEY ARE DOING A
REVIEW.
THIS IS SOMETHING NOW THAT THE
FBI AND THE NATIONAL SECURITY
DIVISION OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ARE DOING A REVIEW
BECAUSE ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
THEY HAVE TO DO IS EXAMINE THE
DOCUMENTS, SEE WHETHER THE
INFORMATION IS STILL CONSIDERED
CLASSIFIED, WHO OWNS IT, WHICH
AGENCY IS BELONGS TO AND TO
DETERMINE HOW THEY CAME TO BE
WHERE THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE, IN AN INSECURE OR UNSECURE
LOCATION WHICH IS THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT'S HOME.
IT IS CLEAR, HOWEVER, THAT, YOU
KNOW, I THINK SOME OF THE
ANSWERS ARE ALREADY OUT THERE.
WE KNOW THAT THE TRANSITION
LET'S JUST SAY AT THE END OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT THE
USUAL KIND, RIGHT?
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRETENDING LIKE
HE WAS NEVER GOING TO LEAVE AND
SO THAT MAY BE PART OF THE
REASON HERE AND AS JAMIE POINTS
OUT, YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR ALSO THAT THIS WAS
NOT A PURPOSEFUL THING, YOU
KNOW, IN COMPARISON TO THE TRUMP
CASE WHO, YOU KNOW, SAID THESE
DOCUMENTS ARE MINE AND I'M NOT
RETURNING THEM.
THE VICE PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM
CLEARLY ACCORDING TO LETTERS
THAT WE'VE OBTAINED THAT THEY'VE
WRITTEN TO THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES
AND TO THE WHITE HOUSE, YOU
KNOW, DESCRIBE A VERY, VERY
COOPERATIVE AND A VERY
DELIBERATIVE PROCESS, YOU KNOW,
THEY ADVISE THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES AND FOLLOWING DAY ON
THURSDAY, THE FBI COMES TO THE
HOME AT 9:30 P.M. AND PICKS UP
THESE DOCUMENTS FROM THE HOME IN
CARAMEL, INDIANA.
SO THERE'S A PROCESS THAT IS
BEING WORKED OUT NOW AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO DETERMINE,
YOU KNOW, HOW MUCH OF A PROBLEM
DO WE HAVE HERE AND THE NEXT
STEPS?
WE'RE TOLD AT THIS POINT, YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, THIS IS BEING
HANDLED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, BY THE PEOPLE WHO DO
THIS KIND OF WORK WHICH IS, YOU
KNOW, LET'S JUST SAY IT HAPPENS
FROM FROM TIME TO TIME.
>> IT HAPPENS FROM FROM TIME TO
TIME.
I WANT TO BRING IN CARRIE
CORDERO INTO THE CONVERSATION.
WE HAVE LEARNED NEW THINGS ALL
THE TIME IN THESE INVESTIGATIONS
SO WANT TO RESERVE FOR OUR
VIEWERS THIS IS A BREAKING NEWS
STORY WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
BUT IN BOTH THE PENCE AND THE
BIDEN DISCOVERIES, THEY WERE
DISCOVERED AND LAWYERS FOR THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT AND THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT IMMEDIATELY
CALLED THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND SAID, WE FOUND THESE
DOCUMENTS.
YOU KNOW, TELL US WHAT TO DO.
TRUMP TOOK THE DOCUMENTS AND
OVER A MONTH'S LONG PERIOD OF
TIME CERTIFIED HE RETURNED THEM
ALL AND THAT'S WHY THEY SERVED A
SEARCH WARRANT.
FROM A LEGAL PERSPECTIVE, WHAT
DOES MERRICK GARLAND AND HIS
TEAM HAVE TO GO THROUGH WHEN IT
COMES TO MIKE PENCE?
>> SO THE INVESTIGATION OF
PROSECUTING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
REALLY DOES TURN ON THE INTENT
BEHIND IT, THE WILLFULNESS, ALL
THE VARIOUS STATUTES THAT APPLY
TO PROSECUTING, MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION TURN ON
SOME KIND OF WILLFUL BEHAVIOR ON
THE PART OF IT.
THAT SO FAR AS WE KNOW SEEMS TO
BE WHAT DISTINGUISHES CERTAINLY
THIS SITUATION WITH FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE, WE'RE STILL
LEARNING MORE ABOUT PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S SITUATION BUT IT SOUNDS
THAT WAY IN PART BECAUSE OF
THEIR DISCLOSURES.
WHAT I THINK A REALLY
INTERESTING DECISION POINT FOR
MERRICK GARLAND, IS HE GOING TO
NEED A SPECIAL COUNSEL IN THIS
CASE AND THAT GETS INTO THE
POLITICS OF IT BECAUSE,
REMEMBER, THE TRIGGER FOR HIM
APPOINTING THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
IN FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CASE
WAS FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ANNOUNCEMENT HE'S A CANDIDATE
AGAIN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS A PRUNING
TIFF CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT.
WHERE IS MIKE PENCE IN THE
POLITICAL SITUATION MOVING
FORWARD AND HOW WILL THAT IMPACT
WHETHER OR NOT ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND NEEDS TO CABIN THIS --
>> YOU HAD A POINT.
>> TWO THINGS WE DIDN'T MAKE
CLEAR, THE FBI DID NOT GO INTO
THE PENCE HOME AND SEARCH THE
HOME, WHICH IS DIFFERENT FROM
BIDEN.
THEY JUST CAME AND PICKED UP THE
PAPERS, SO AS EVAN SAID THERE'S
A REVIEW GOING ON BUT IT'S NOT
THE KIND OF CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION WHERE THEY WANT TO
SEE WHERE WERE THE BOXES KEPT?
WHAT WERE THE SURROUNDING
THINGS?
SO THEY HAVEN'T TAKEN THAT NEXT
STEP YET AND ONE OTHER POINT --
>> FORGIVE ME, HOLD THE OTHER
POINT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
BIDEN --
>> CORRECT.
>> THEY TURNED THEM -- TURNED
OVER WHAT THEY FOUND THE FIRST
TIME THEN THERE WERE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT TO DO
NEXT.
I BELIEVE, CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG, THEY TURNED OVER
ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTS AND STILL
DECIDED THEY NEEDED TO DO A
THOROUGH SEARCH.
>> PARTLY BECAUSE OF, FRANKLY,
LET'S JUST BE HONEST, THE BIDEN
CASE WAS SCREWED UP, RIGHT?
THE WAY THE BIDEN TEAM DECIDED
TO DISCLOSE THESE THINGS
PUBLICLY AND TO WITHHOLD CERTAIN
INFORMATION, CERTAINLY I THINK
GAVE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT A
LITTLE BIT OF CONCERN ABOUT
EXACTLY WHAT WAS HAPPENING AND
THEY NEEDED TO FIGURE OUT, YOU
KNOW, THEY NEEDED TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOTHING ELSE WAS THERE AND
THAT'S WHY THEY TOOK THAT
ADDITIONAL STEP OF DOING A
SEARCH.
YOU KNOW, WHICH WE'VE NOW HAVE
SEEN DISCLOSED.
>> SO THE OTHER QUESTION IS
RAISED IS, WHAT ABOUT FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND FORMER
PRESIDENT BUSH AND THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENTS?
IS THERE GOING TO BE -- I DON'T
SAY THIS TO BE FUNNY, SOME KIND
OF AMNESTY WHERE THEY GO BACK
HOW MANY SPECIAL COUNSELS ARE WE
GOING TO HAVE.
>> OR CAN YOU HAVE SOME SORT OF
NONPARTISAN OR BIPARTISAN LOOK
AT THIS.